how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder
yesterday episode five of the falcon and
the winter soldier was released and
wow there was a lot thrown into one
episode but the episode was over an hour
long by
one minute but we have a lot to break
down so let's go ahead and get started
but of course
be sure to subscribe if you love marvel
and want to stay up to date on all of
the latest marvel news
now to start off episode 5 is titled
truth
which is pretty fitting because the
theme of truth is very apparent in this
episode
sam has to face the truth so does bucky
so does zemo so does john walker but
specifically
isaiah bradley reveals a big truth about
how the us government treated him
decades ago and truth is actually the
title of the comic storyline that was
about isaiah bradley and what they did
to him
and considering that that's a pretty big
moment in this episode especially for
sam who is now struggling with
what to do with the shield and what it
means to him that's a great little
easter egg and a very well titled
episode
episode 5 truth starts off where we left
off in episode 4.
john walker has just killed the flax
master nico and now he's running away
trying to get away from the crowd and
all of the people that were recording
him
he runs into a warehouse where he
immediately starts to talk
to lamar like he's there he relives
moments in his head where lamar was
talking to him and he talks to him
saying
you told me you didn't want me to go in
why didn't i
listen this is also kind of a scene from
the comics as well
in the comics jon's parents were
actually murdered and he speaks to them
all the time as if they are actually
there so in this scene instead of his
parents he's talking to lamar
after grieving for a short period jon
cracks his neck and just like lamar
would say he says
time to go to work however bucky and
falcon have tracked him down
that shield means a lot to both of them
and they are not okay with what jon just
did
but for the most part they seem to be
pretty understanding but they want the
shield back
jon refuses and we get an incredible
fight scene
a fight scene that actually mirrors two
different captain america movies and a
slightly altered
scene from the comics where steve rogers
actually fights john walker to get back
the shield
the one-on-one fighting between bucky
and john walker are very similar to the
fighting styles that we saw in captain
america the winter soldier which
makes sense because bucky who was the
winner soldier in that movie
was fighting captain america so it's
kind of the same here
bucky is fighting the new captain
america and then of course we have
big captain america civil war vibes here
where steve rogers captain america and
bucky fought against iron man
only this time bucky is fighting with
who should be the new captain america
and the person who he believes shouldn't
be now remember john walker took the
super soldier serum last episode and
according to dr nagel who designed this
serum it is a perfect
serum bucky does not have a perfect
serum he got one from hydra
and sam doesn't have any serum in him at
all so john walker
actually puts up a really big fight
against them and almost defeats them and
john walker's kind of starting to go a
little bit crazy here notice how
when he's fighting he says why are you
making me do this and during the fight
he actually tries to kill them several
times
trying to slam his shield into their
heads however after breaking his arm and
smashing the heck out of him with the
shield
they defeat him and bucky drops the
shield just like steve dropped his
shield to tony during civil war
only this time he drops it to sam who is
going to take on the mantle of captain
america and it's interesting here that
he drops it because he himself
doesn't want to be the new captain
america him and steve talked about it
and steve told him that he thought
sam should be the new captain america so
he gives sam the shield because that's
what he wants as well
sam picks up the shield and with a very
very upset face
starts to wipe the blood off of it
feeling somewhat responsible for what
happened because he gave up the shield
and also incredibly sad that this huge
symbol to him has now just murdered at
the hands of jon
now all of the events that took place
the last episode and the previous
episodes end up blowing up and the us
government steps
in and basically tells sam that he can't
go after the flag smashers anymore that
they're going to handle it themselves
falcon now has the shield and he leaves
his wings with torres
this is kind of like sam leaving the
mantle of falcon behind and him starting
to accept the mantle of captain america
this is also the start of torres
becoming falcon which happens in the
comics when sam becomes captain america
torres becomes falcon so sam leaves his
wings with torres who will most likely
fix them and then use them himself
walker is then brought in front of a
senate council hearing to answer for his
crimes and pay for what he did and this
is also a reflection of a scene in the
comics where captain america brings john
walker to court to pay for his crimes
now walker actually believes that
he didn't really do anything wrong the
flag smashers are terrorists and they
killed lamar
so all he did in his mind was kill a
terrorist but the government has decided
that he disgraced america and they strip
him of his title of captain america
and to make matters even worse they
strip him of all the benefits that he
would have had being a retired
soldier upset with the judgment and his
penalty he states that he is captain
america
and he walks out of the hearing he tells
his wife that they just don't know what
it takes to be captain america
and then we get the episode 5 cameo that
we've been talking about for a very long
time
a woman approaches jon and his wife and
it's julia louise dreyfus and the
character that she is playing is
contessa valentina allegra de fontaine
also known as madame hydra in the
comments she was once a shield agent and
at one point in the comics she was also
nick fury's lover she eventually joins
hydra and takes on the name
madame hydra which means that hydra
could still be
alive and well working in the background
so she basically says that she knows jon
took the serum and that makes him pretty
valuable to certain people
and of course she is talking about
herself and she tells him that the best
decision he'll ever make is picking up
the phone when she calls
so of course the big question is who is
she
could she be the power broker it does
seem like she wants to use jon to take
out the flag smashers
and as we know the power broker wants
the flag smashers dead
however we did hear sharon carter refer
to the power broker as
a he so perhaps madame hydra is simply
working for the power broker whatever
her role is it's going to be big because
variety just released an article only
yesterday stating that it's been
revealed that her character was actually
supposed to debut
in the black widow film and marvel has
big plans for her moving forward so
whoever she is and whatever her role is
she is definitely a big player we then
cut to zemo he is at the sokovia
memorial
and when we see him we actually hear the
same music that played for him in civil
war
bucky appears and zemo was actually
expecting him saying that he expected
him sooner
so zemo wasn't actually hiding when he
ran away in the last episode he was just
simply trying to get away from the dora
milaje he tells bucky that
carly is already out of control and
she's not coming back and that he'll
have to kill her to stop her
bucky has different plans though when he
points a gun at zemo's head
pulls the trigger and it's empty he
drops the bullets on the ground
and doesn't kill zemo because that's the
whole point
bucky isn't the winter soldier anymore
he isn't a
killer anymore zemo forgives him because
he understands that hydra brainwashed
him before
and he understands him turning him into
the dormilage who promptly appear
they explained that they're going to
take him to the raft and this
is big the raft we actually saw in
captain america civil war it's that
prison that sits
in the middle of the ocean it's super
maximum security and holds many
different criminals in the comics but
as we know this is ran by thunderbolt
ross who of course goes on to start the
thunderbolts in the comics
and what a coincidence the first person
to lead the thunderbolts in the comics
is
zemo now i've been talking about this
for a while so i won't dive super into
it but the thunderbolts are coming
ross is going to start to assemble them
and he most likely has some other bad
guys
in the raft already and he's going to
pretty much be like a
kid in a candy shop he's just going to
go into the raft and kind of pick what
he wants to assemble his team
heck taskmaster is probably already in
there since the events of black widow
happen
way before the events of the falcon and
the winter soldier so it looks like this
actually could be the first hint towards
the thunderbolts team coming together in
the mcu in the future
now before bucky parts ways with the
door milaji ayo tells him that he should
probably steer clear from wakanda for a
bit and this is because
he released zemo out of jail and the
wakandans hate zemo because he killed
king t'chaka
so they're probably pretty mad at bucky
right now or the white wolf as they call
him
and right before they part ways bucky
asks for a favor
and this favor is the briefcase that he
goes on to give sam
more on this in just a little bit we
then cut to sam who is going to visit
isaiah bradley as he walks up to the
house he sees his grandson
elijah in the comics elijah is patriot
and he's a founding member of the young
avengers
we've already had plenty of setups for
the young avengers coming in the mcu
and the fact that eli has been
introduced to the mcu is more evidence
that the young avengers are coming
and soon sam goes and he talks to isaiah
and he learns
the truth the tragic story that is
pretty much straight from marvel comics
the story of how they took 300 black men
and injected them with super soldier
serum not telling them what it really
was
the serum killed pretty much all of the
men except for a handful of them
isaiah explains that some of the
survivors of the serum were then taken
hostage
and he heard them say that they were
going to blow up the prisoner of
war camp where they were kept to get rid
of the evidence of the super soldiers so
isaiah went out of his facility
broke into the prisoner of war camp and
rescued the men
this is something that he does in the
comics as well but in the comics he
actually takes captain america shield
and puts on the uniform and then goes to
save them and that's actually why they
put him in jail in the comics because he
stole the shield in uniform
but in this series they put him in jail
and they experiment on him for
30 years because as he explains
everybody but him even the people that
he rescued started to die from the super
soldier serum until it was just him
so they experimented on him to figure
out why he survived
why the serum worked for him they told
his wife that he was dead
and when he finally escaped thanks to
the help of a nurse who took pity on him
they erased him meaning they took his
dame and everything that he did out of
every single database and records that
they have on file
isaiah bradley does not exist and isaiah
actually prefers this at this point
because he believes that if people know
that he's alive
they're just going to kill him now
isaiah's story essentially makes sam
question if he should even pick up the
shield after so much wrong was done to
isaiah
however this episode is really about
choices later on in the episode sam even
tells bucky that steve is dead and you
can't let somebody else tell you who you
are you have to choose who you want to
be just like walker is choosing to still
be captain america even though he's
stripped of that title and how sam
is choosing to be the true captain
america even though so much wrong has
been done to those before him
sam then returns home to his sister
sarah and his nephews calls in some
favors that the neighborhood owed his
parents because his parents were awesome
to them and the community comes together
to fix their boat which they're trying
to sell
bucky even comes and delivers a
briefcase to sam he then starts to help
work on the boat as well
we have some good feel happy scenes and
then ultimately sam and sarah decide not
to sell the boat because it's their
family's history
we then see sharon carter and she is
quite confusing at this point in time in
the series
she's either gone off the deep end
completely or she's playing everybody
could she herself be the power broker
there is a funny little theory going on
right now that she is the power broker
because in the series she's actually
holding an
android phone whereas other people are
using iphones and apple actually has
some strict rules for
iphones in their movies their rule is
villains and movies can't be seen
using iphones iphones can only be used
by good
people no villains and sharon actually
has an android
now this doesn't mean she's a villain
it's a funny theory but maybe they're
just going for a little misdirection
here
and it does seem a little less likely
that she's the power broker now because
she's actually helping the flag smashers
big reveal about sharon in captain
america the winter soldier
bartrock the leaper fought captain
america he escaped but was later
captured by shield and thrown into an
algerian prison now we find out here
that
sharon was actually the one that got him
out of prison and she actually hired him
to do the kidnapping in the very first
episode of the falcon and the winter
soldier the one that sam
thwarted so she calls bar truck and
hires him again saying i can offer you
double this time and he eventually goes
on to give the flax master some weapons
and says that he's trying to kill
falcon so like i said sharon carter is
either going off the deep end and
actually doesn't care whether falcon or
bucky or anybody gets killed because her
government kind of betrayed her or she
has some very
very big plans in store to get the flax
masters and the power broker
i really don't think she's evil and i
definitely don't think that she actually
wants falcon dead i definitely think she
has a plan that we're going to see
happen in the next episode
bucky stays the night over at falcon's
house and when he awakes we can see that
he's wearing dog tags and as i mentioned
in some previous videos
i think these are the dog tags of steve
rogers i think he left them to bucky
when he left because unless hydra kept
bucky's dog tags and then gave them to
him which i very much doubt they did
he doesn't have his own so i think these
could be steve's now before he leaves
bucky and sam have a very truthful
conversation as they're throwing around
steve rogers
shield and as we learned in captain
america the winter soldier sam
was a veterans counselor and in this
scene he severely helps bucky he tells
bucky that he was simply avenging which
is a great little avengers pun
he was avenging not amending and that he
actually needed to make amends and make
people feel better instead of doing
things to make
him feel better sam says i'm sure
there's at least one person that comes
to mind that you could help right now
and of course
bucky and all of us are thinking about
yori who we met in the first episode and
we found out that
bucky is actually responsible for
killing his son well
not bucky the winter soldier was bucky
killed him as the winter soldier when he
was under hydra's command
yori's name is on bucky's list in steve
rogers book that he has
he's been trying to make amends with him
but hasn't been able to summon the
courage to do it yet because it's a very
hard thing to tell him
but he's definitely going to do this in
the next episode and something peculiar
to note here
is how they talk about steve being gone
but notice how nobody ever says that
steve
died and even in the memorial museum for
captain america steve rogers they don't
say anything about him dying they just
said that he lived his life
so we really don't know what happened to
steve rogers at this point did he go
back to his own timeline or did he live
out sharon carter and stay in the main
timeline where he could have eventually
died
marvel can be pretty peculiar with their
words so i wouldn't be surprised if
steve actually went back to the old
timeline or if he's still alive
but they talk about how steve was their
connection to each other and now he's
gone so
now the two of them are friends now and
it's a great moment between the two of
them where bucky says that if you need
me
i'll be there for you and they actually
go from two people who
kind of hated each other to friends and
side note i was very wrong about this
being the final scene in the falcon in
the winter soldier and i'm glad i was
wrong because
i don't want to see them part ways i
hope they stick together even after the
series
now from here sam begins to prepare to
become captain america
throwing the shield in a way that peter
parker has described as defying the laws
of physics
and not obeying them at all he practices
throwing the shield and catching it
doing a bunch of maneuvers he runs
around the house telling his nephews
all day man a reference to steve rogers
catchphrase i can do this all day
we are literally witnessing sam go from
the falcon to captain america
we cut to the flag smashers who are
revealed to be in new york they're going
to interrupt the grc
vote this vote is whether or not to move
the refugees back to their original
countries but as it's revealed by the
u.s senator who still remains nameless
that's not really much of a vote he
pretty much already decided and the
people are in place to move them back
this is not okay with the flax smashers
and it looks like they've gained a
pretty big following and they
infiltrate the grc much like hydra
infiltrated shield
and we learned that they're in new york
and their attack on the grc
has begun now torres gives sam a call
telling him that he thinks he's pinged
the location of the flag smashers in new
york and while sam looks at the tv he
sees that the grc meeting is in new york
and he realizes that yes
this is where the flag smashes are and
they're going to attack the grc
sam goes to the box that bucky left him
and he opens it
now what's in this box is his new
captain america suit made from wakandan
technology and most likely has vibranium
arms that can't get ripped off by a
super soldier
and since it's wakandan technology we
probably can assume that it's going to
have the same energy components that
t'challa aka the black panther suit has
being able to absorb energy and then
release it even if it doesn't have that
and just has vibranium wings i am super
excited to finally see this new captain
america suit for sam in the final
episode now in the post-credits scene we
see walker
making his own captain america shield
notice that his arm which was broken
is now fine thanks to the super soldier
serum that he took which essentially
gives him super healing but this shield
is going to be way different than the
one that he's had
i know some people are saying that this
shield could be made out of vibranium
because
if julia louie dreyfus's character
valentina is in fact mata hydra and
hydra is still around they could have
given him some vibranium however i
very very much doubt that that's the
case it can't be vibranium because you
can't just melt vibranium and you can't
just bend it with a hammer like he's
doing
cap's shield has taken full straight on
blast from mjolnir
several times in the mcu and the uru
hammer never even scratched it so john
walker is not just going to be able to
make his own vibranium shield by bending
and forging vibranium
into a new shield so it's not going to
be nearly as strong as vibranium so i'm
guessing that this shield is not going
to hold very well and act
nearly the same as a vibranium show
would however we have
seen a scene of john walker walking
through the street with the new shield
a shield that he has fused his medal of
honor with because he does believe that
he
is the true captain america and since he
lied to lamar's family telling them that
nico was actually the one that killed
lamar and that he avenged him by killing
nico
when in fact it was really carly that
killed lamar he has to go after carly
now and that's exactly what he's going
to do
next episode and i'll be breaking that
down too so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any future videos be sure to let
me know what you would rate episode 5
out of 10
in the comments down below and let me
know what your favorite part was
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof